[Music]
and see you again he was one man I
haven't seen you since your dance with
the Stars day hold the dancing days man
fun you are back at it reality TV this
time selected Big Brother how's it going
so far how you handling yourself I mean
so far it's been pretty easy
yeah I've been actually my first day and
God knows how many years I haven't had
to be on my phone emails taking Caleb
care of every facet of business and
honestly pretty stress-free about it
yeah you know easy you're in the easy
part you're saying it's inevitable that
that change are you saying there's gonna
be drama good she's some trouble is
gonna be a little bit of stress my
friend all right so let's let's back up
a little real fat are you fan of the
show do you know this show how do you
become yes and this is actually one of
the only shows that I have watched over
the years you know that watched every
episode every time not sure some of my
friends are super fans and they've
filled me in and all the gaps I may have
not watched yeah I don't watch a whole
lot of TV but this has been one of the
more most interesting shows and that's
part of the reason when they ask me if I
want to do it oh yeah how fun would that
be
yeah you're gonna have to get rid of
your cell phone like you say but B
you're gonna have all these cameras what
are you most worried about yeah me to be
quite frank I'm very uncomfortable in
front of cameras and people would be
like what do you mean I'm in front of
camera G whole life but acting playing a
character I love that that's what I
trained for is what I study for or if
you're filming me on stage I don't even
know cameras there I'm singing those
that's what I do so yes but that's part
of the reason I'm doing this it's very
much gonna be a challenge so I'm nervous
because I've never really given that
much of my private life away right but
I'm also excited cuz it's just another
thing to get better at or more used to I
guess can't hurt yeah yeah yeah here's
everyday you know initially when they
started asking me questions about those
even before I was on camera the like hey
so are you gonna do this or that and I
kind of went that's not my personality
cuz it isn't I'd like to be a
problem-solver I'm very pragmatic and
realistic and I hope that there are
other people that see things for those
that same scope but at the same time if
somebody is going to push me I have a
really hard time just taking it so
that's when I'll probably take the show
a little more seriously fine a little
bit
strategy and maybe even play into some
of the drama that I don't necessarily
like because I'd rather be better at the
game than somebody else okay
strategically all right how careful do
you feel like you need to be I'd like as
far as like you worry about anything
when people do this show they get to go
back and just live their lives and
really have no consequences you you
continue to be under like the spotlight
in some degree so or in some degree but
I get to go back home you know and I
mean get back in my house and go on runs
on the beach to sleep in my bed I mean
it's gonna be entirely different okay
but yet to that points you know we all
say things you know I have a very crude
sense of humor for example and of course
it's gonna come out when we're sitting
there for you know potentially weeks in
one house and I wouldn't I guess that
about you most people wouldn't know if
you talk to my friends I laugh cuz you
don't know that and I'm gonna do my best
to be respectful things but I find
sometimes inappropriate things very
funny and if that does come out I hope
people you know look into the context of
it and don't I think we're very
sensitive there's a generation
especially and as a culture these days
and there is definitely validity to some
of the sensitivity but like when it
comes to a joke I hope people would have
a good sense of humor that's almost I am
alright so on the show there's often
show manses as we call them
what's your dating status is that a
possibility for you well that's kind of
shifted in the past what six or eight
weeks I thought I'd be perpetually
single in this crazy town of Los Angeles
I have been single the past four years
yeah and then just started hanging out
with a wonderful gal I don't ever
actually use the word yeah but girl felt
adolescent we've been hanging out for a
little bit now and I think it's turned
into what people call dating I don't
think it's full-blown like
girlfriend/boyfriend yet but I I think
I'm gonna do my best to just focus on
the show as as work and stick the
strategy and if I meet somebody cool
then great but I think I'm at the point
where to be a little disrespectful to
have a showmance yeah but you know I
mean here's the thing as you're living
in close quarters and they're generally
are often attractive people on the show
I'm sure there will be you know it might
be it might be a challenge but I've been
around attractive girls for long before
I was famous and I've done okay I think
that you know I need your confidence I
got a pretty good one that I've been
hanging out with back at home and I
don't think it's worth screwing that up
for whatever's on the house stay and
staying focus on yeah all right so what
about food can be a little tough will
slop you open for all this how you gonna
roll you know what's funny I'm sure I
mean I train on a regular basis but I've
if I could have come into this show
being a little stricter on my diet a
little stricter in training so be it
having said that I'm kind of looking
forward to keeping everything pretty
strict for the next you know a few weeks
or a month I like that I like the
challenge of like oh well I'm gonna cook
myself all meal prep must sweet potato
my chicken my steak and veggies like I
hope that's what I'm gonna eat and if it
gets to the poor I gotta do slop for a
week or so why not I mean it's not that
big of a deal
I eat oatmeal and stuff every morning
anyway so I feel like it's gonna be just
another version of that all right play
this back play this back when I'm
bitching about it on the show you gotta
go you know what other attitude can you
have I appreciate that for sure let me
ask you this as far as being on camera
as far as you know like worrying about
what you might say he talked about being
inappropriate is there something you
know is are you gonna be playing a
character here are you gonna allow
yourself to be your authentic self I'm
gonna do my best
honestly all right I think the more I do
even interviews the more you know I've
done 10 years of this profession at this
point the more comfortably get but as I
said when it's just me on camera and
it's not me performing not maybe playing
a character saying it's always been a
little weird I think this show will
force a more genuine version of myself
but if it's just so ridiculous and it's
easier for me to be the goofball if I
feel that the show needs that if you
were being too serious yeah it might be
a little bit of a character unless you
will see play read the road right now
are we talking about you being on
Dancing with the Stars
versus this what do you think is gonna
be more difficult more stressful had I
not done that show I don't think there's
any way I would have said yes to this
one quite honestly but I'm glad that I
did I think that it set me up for
success in the show because I've had a
taste of it I've had a taste of cameras
around at all times at times when you're
frustrated at times with in my
professional life I had somebody doing
behind this
at a concert and I'm pissed off I turn
to go yo take it outside because I don't
yeah who wants that out there it's
different this world you need to be
honest nothing to get every point and
nobody's constantly happy nobody's
constantly energetic and so I don't know
like I said in a weird way I think that
would be a valuable skill set to have to
get more comfortable with it especially
the way the world is going in the way
this industry is you know non-scripted
is a big part of the world it's
something I'm actually open to doing
maybe even after the show all right
so if that's a lesson learned after this
to be more comfortable that's kind of
awesome if you do win okay on that note
oftentimes when people do these reality
shows they have more opportunities out
there what are you how are you hoping
this affects your your career and your
exposure and future opportunities
absolutely um you know though it's
obvious I just released a single called
falling I'm excited if I get a few more
people listen to that song and I'm a
previous album that's great got a movie
called bachelor lions going to theaters
here in the near future if more people
watch that that's fantastic but to you
know your point previous about like
danger the Stars how was that experience
and after that I was offered so many
hosting things for example so many
things that I just went you know no
that's not really what I want to do I
just just want to keep acting and just
singing keep more traditional in just a
few years I think the industry has
changed and my mindset has changed so
after this there's an opportunity to
host a reality show for example or
something along the lines that is a
little unconventional I might jump at
that now
whereas I probably wouldn't have a few
years ago sounds like people judge it
the same way that you know they know
they're more accepting of people being a
little have their foot Jamie Foxx
hosting you if Mark Wahlberg knew a
reality show I mean it doesn't in no
ways any detriment to what they really
do with acting and in performing so I
think the world is changing and I'm
excited about it alright the similar
photos were released of the house we got
to see that you each get your own bed
yes that must have been something you
were happy about that was quite a relief
yeah you got an espresso machines you
catch that I'm excited about that you
know I'm sorry yeah no that's that's
such a game changer right there cap gene
these days I've seen as an attitude
change your house the house look you
know from your first glasses yeah it
looks gorgeous
you know I mean I mean look there will
be stressful moments no doubt what big
picture like if anybody's going into
this in any other way
than thinking like this is kind of like
a vacation then they're ridiculous
like we got all the food when you
provide it we got a great house good to
interact with other people hopefully in
some capacity in my industry make new
friends I mean that's really at it is
honestly how I'm going into it I know
you people are smiling having a home be
it so I want to replay this vacation